building sites in the Colombian capital
Bogota remain idle
despite the announcement by president
even Duque that construction and
manufacturing were due to gradually
restore Monday that's because late
Sunday night the mayor of Bogota managed
to postpone the return to work of almost
a million people in this city alone
nobody starts working tomorrow
nobody no businesses no construction
science the only thing starting tomorrow
is the registry of the businesses to
approve their protocols the political
infighting shows just how difficult it
is to safely restart work in populous
than cities like Bogota the measure
might delay reopening for another two
weeks as companies wait for their
security and mobility plans to be
approved by the city something that
worries entrepreneurs who are you going
to restart we had already informed our
workers and it was a surprise to find
out at 8 p.m. that we couldn't work and
that we had to fill a lot of new
paperwork we are bewildered it's clear
the different levels of government are
not working together and this damages
everybody Colombia has been in full
lockdown for over a month which has
helped slow the rate of infections but
has also badly hurt its poorest citizens
for the government the biggest worry
lies here in the public transportation
system which they say can't operate past
35% capacity to avoid putting people at
serious risk some workers say safety
must remain paramount I'm going to pick
up some things at work we were expected
to start today but instead were working
home any longer it's tough but it's
worth it to avoid the worst health
crisis economy Scott Harris therapist is
finding the right balance will be
difficult they need to allow people to
start working is very high and local
governments and the national government
need to balance the act in order to try
to avoid a large increase in the number
of people continue 8 it or basically
create social unrest calm
from the lack of income this conundrum
is not Columbia's alone Ecuador Chile
and Argentina are also trying to ease
some restrictions to restart part of
their economy while also extending the
lockdowns
it shows just how scared everybody is to
watch what the restrictions had achieved
so far
alessandro MPT al Jazeera Bogota